visionnaire ambitieux disruptif
charismatique fougueux séducteur et
pourquoi pas vous vous rêvez de marcher
dans les pas du plus grand inventeur de
ce siècle mais avant toute chose sachez
vous ce qui fait le succès d'Elon musk
connaissez-vous ce qui lui a permis de
provoquer sa chance sans jamais se
départir de l'humilité et la sagesse
qu'il caractérise vous l'aviez deviné
c'est en effet la richesse non pas de
ses parents ça faut pas le dire mais la
richesse géologique de son pays
d'origine l'Afrique du Sud alors si vous
brûlez d'envie de devenir le prochain
Elon Musk prenez d'abord une page du
livre de son pays natal voici
gratuitement mon programme en 10 points
pour s'inspirer de l'Afrique du Sud et
donc dès le LOSC
[Musique]
premier point soyez vital comme
l'oxygène de l'air émis par les tous
premiers organismes photosynthétiques il
y a plusieurs milliards d'années ces
organismes sont des cyanobactéries comme
celles qui rendent les cours d'eau
indénibles en été et qui tuent vos
toutous s'ils ont la mauvaise idée d'en
boire oui c'est machin-là sont
multimillaires comme elon
on dirait pas comme ça mais c'est simple
cellule c'était les premières capables
de faire de la photosynthèse c'est à
dire des maîtres de l'oxygène à partir
de CO2 et d'eau et de lumière pour les
condosseurs c'est même ces bactéries qui
sera devenues des chloroplastes des
plantes et des algues quand d'autres
bactéries les ont avalé et que les deux
parties ont décidé de vivre en symbiose
et paf ça a fait des eucaryotes
photosyntiques bon une cellule c'est
bien mignon mais mou comme un Flanby
c'est pas ça qui va s'utiliser encore
moins traverser des milliards d'années
alors comment qu'on en a des traces de
ces bidules et bien parce que ces
bactéries sont Malines elles
construisent des cailloux elle se met
toutes les unes à côté des autres pour
former un tapis et ça travaille sec pour
construire un toit de calcaire au dessus
d'elle puis la génération suivante
colonise la croûte de calcaire et en
forme une autre par dessus et ainsi de
suite l'immeuble Le se construit en bord
de plage les pieds dans l'eau cet
immeuble c'est ce qu'on appelle un
stromatolite et il peut prendre
différentes formes selon l'humeur des
architectes bactériens on aura aussi
bien un lotissement de banlieue qu'une
audacieuse Grande-Motte et alors donc
c'est stromatolites on en trouve vieux
de 3,5 milliards d'années dans le nord
de l'Afrique du Sud en Afrique du milieu
à barbec Chan à bout de SAP je sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte c'est non
seulement des fossiles des premiers
organismes photosynthétiques connus sur
terre mais ils sont aussi parmi les plus
vieux fossiles tout court aux côtés
d'autres stromatolites australiens ces
immeubles c'est vraiment la preuve qui
avait déjà des trucs vivants sous forme
de cellules un petit milliards d'années
après la naissance de la terre c'est
rien
et ce sont eux qui ont littéralement
changé la face de la planète à l'époque
puisqu'en inventant la photosynthèse ils
sont mis à émettre de l'oxygène qui
avait pas du tout avant en tout cas
pensé quantité et donc peu à peu chemin
faisant il y a eu de plus en plus
d'oxygène dans les océans où se trouver
les cyanobactéries et une fois les
océans saturés en oxygène ces bactéries
ont commencé à injecter de l'oxygène
dans l'atmosphère et voilà comment on a
pu aboutir à toute la vie qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui sur terre donc merci aux
minuscule architectes qui ont construit
ces immeubles sans doute
deuxième leçon avoir du beef c'est
l'acronyme de bandit iron formation de
faire rubaner pour les intimes comme si
une BIF s'était pas assez intime c'était
des roches très très vieilles qui date
de l'Archéon qui contiennent de
l'hématite et qui surtout se sont formés
uniquement au moment dont on parlait
juste avant quand l'oxygène est arrivé
dans les océans grâce à nosyanobactéries
c'est une histoire incroyable parce que
à la base avant d'être vital l'oxygène
c'est un poison les premiers organismes
vivants étaient pas du tout adaptés ils
sont fait oxyder la Tron donc on pense
que pendant que ces bifs se formaient et
dû avoir un beau petit carnage sur terre
avant que la vie ne commence à se dire
tiens tiens tiens cet oxygène et si au
lieu de nous tuer on s'en servait pour
respirer innovation réaction adaptation
prenez des notes en tout cas les bips ça
fait vraiment partie de mes trucs
préférés j'espère très très fort pouvoir
avoir en vrai un jour et vous en parler
plus en détail à ce moment là
[Musique]
troisième point soyez imprévisible comme
la météorite s'est abattue à Fred au
sud-ouest de Johannesbourg c'est le
deuxième plus vieux cratère de
météorites encore préservée et c'est
surtout l'un des plus grands connus sur
terre vous voyez le trou creusé par la
météorite qui a anéanti les dinosaures
dans le golfe du Mexique et bah celui-là
était deux fois plus gros à sa formation
la taille de l'Irlande le caillou qui
s'est abattu à stop le faux podcast là
c'est bon je prends le relais donc je
disais le caillou qui s'est abattu à
frais de foot à la vitesse de 15 à 25
km/h par seconde mesurait 20 à 25 km de
diamètre un bon gros caillou c'est
encore plus gros que la météorite qui a
zigouyet Denver et ses copains des
enjeux de cette taille on les appelle
des astroblèmes sauf que à l'opposé de
la dynôme météorite il y avait pas trop
de vie à zigouiller a priori du coup
quand la météorite a fendu le ciel
personne n'a dû s'écrier astroi Houston
on a un astroblème et rien que ça c'est
plus triste que l'extinction des
dinosaures mais même s'il y avait moins
de vie a priori que des trucs gélatineux
dans les océans ça a quand même du
vachement secouer la planète à l'époque
en provoquant des séismes pendant
plusieurs siècles voire millénaires tout
en changeant l'atmosphère de poussière
et voilà que l'air soit pacifique et
qu'avec moins de lumière du soleil ça
refroidit
[Musique]
entracte science Julien à ton tour salut
Fiona
mais ça va très bien et toi
alors le bassin du carrous c'est un
grand bassin sédimentaire qui se situe
en Afrique du Sud il fait à peu près la
taille de la France et correspond à une
accumulation Marno graisseuse sur à peu
près 10 km d'épaisseur qui documente
l'évolution de la vie pendant 100
millions d'années entre le Carbonifère
et le Jurassic et c'est un bassin qui
est extrêmement important pour nous
paléontologue à étudier puisque il
documente l'origine de deux groupes
majeurs celui des reptiles avec
notamment les ancêtres des dinosaures
mais aussi celui des mammifères avec le
groupe des thérapsides les thérapsides
sont les ancêtres des mammifères ils ont
vécu entre le Carbonifère et le
Jurassique et ils avaient la
particularité d'avoir une biologie plus
reptilienne que ma malienne à savoir
qu'il devait certainement pondre des
œufs ne pas posséder des poils et comme
ce magnifique plutôt avoir les bras et
les jambes sur le côté du corps au lieu
de les avoir dressés sous le corps comme
les mammifères modernes
oui ouais oui
la limite permienrias c'est un événement
géologique extrêmement important il
s'agit d'une grande crise d'extinction
de masse 90% de ce qui existait à
disparu c'est il y a 250 millions
d'années le moment où la vie a failli
disparaître et ça ça en fait le deuxième
événement le plus important de toute
l'histoire de la vie à part l'origine de
la vie elle-même et cette extinction
permet un Trias on en a que très très
peu d'enregistrements complets dans le
registre fossile il n'y en a que deux en
réalité un en Chine et un en Afrique du
Sud et c'est pour toutes ces raisons que
ce serait super bien si toi et Valentine
vous pouviez nous rejoindre hein
et tout ça peut-être grâce à vous êtes
vous prêt à nous aider à réaliser le
rêve de Fiona
[Musique]
cinquième élément soyez un socle pour
votre entourage comme la croûte
continentale est un socle pour le
carreau la plupart des formations aux
choses sont comme vos stagiaires
instables versatile changeante ils se
font broyer par le système comme les
plaques dans les rouages de la
tectonique et ils en ressortent
transformés mes connaissances pire
encore syndiqués au contraire soyez
fidèles à vous-même ne cédez pas aux
sirènes de la tectonique des plaques
inspirez-vous plutôt des rares morceaux
de croûte continentales qui n'ont pas
bougé depuis des milliards d'années on
les appelle des crates pareil un maître
préféré et ce qu'on trouve sous le
carreau et l'Afrique du Sud est l'un des
très rares endroits on peut fouler ces
reliques des débuts de la planète avec
son Kraton du cap-val un beau morceau de
1 million 200000 km2 qui aurait 2,5 à
3,6 milliards d'années et c'est
justement grâce à lui qu'on trouve des
diamants en Afrique du Sud parce que
comme ce bout de croûte est vieux il est
épais bon appétit
et comme il était payé les volcans qui
ont poussé prélevé leurs laves très en
profondeur en moyenne trois fois plus
loin qu'un volcan normal ce magma est la
composition chimique particulière crée
des roches tout aussi particulières
qu'on appelle des Kimberley baptisé
d'après la plus vieille mine de diamants
d'Afrique du Sud dans la ville de
Kimberley et c'est donc là comme Crétacé
des cheminées volcaniques ont accouché
du lave très particulier des volcans
depuis le manteau supérieur à votre tour
au prochain brainstorming tel l'Afrique
du Sud accouché de diamant ou de pépites
ça marche aussi parce qu'on y trouve
aussi plein d'or et même du platine en
fait quasi la moitié de tout leur minet
sur Terre dans l'histoire provient de ce
bassin en Afrique du Sud on y a trouvé
tellement d'or que c'est à failli
provoquer une crise économique à
l'époque
[Musique]
huitième astuce reconnectez-vous avec
vos ancêtres dont le plus grand nombre
est ici dans le berceau de l'humanité
incite à 50 km au nord de Johannesburg
et encore une fois classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO décidément et c'est
pas pour rien c'est là qu'on a trouvé le
tout premier spécimen d'australopithèque
l'enfant de tong ainsi que le squelette
le plus complet baptisé little foot
l'enfant de tong c'est un crâne
appartenant à un Pitchoun ayant vécu il
y a 2,3 millions d'années en Afrique du
Sud ce reste ont été découvert 50 ans
avant Lucie en 1925 et c'est cela Redon
qui a permis à son découvreur de décrire
à la fois un nouveau genre d'hominidé
les australopithèque et une nouvelle
espèce australopiticus africanus il a
même été qualifié de fossiles
anthropologiques le plus important du
XXe siècle l'enfant de tongue pas le
découvrir inspirez-vous de ce Kido lui
il a réussi sa vie enfin plutôt sa mort
on a trouvé des traces de Serdaigle dans
les orbites de son crâne qui montre que
le garçon né a été traîné par un aigle
qui l'a chopé par les trous des yeux ça
c'est de la sortie de scène pensez-y
pour votre prochaine TEDx et petit pied
alias LittleFoot c'est le fossile
d'australopithèque le plus complet qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui il a été découvert
dans les années 90 et aurait 3,67
millions d'années plus vieux que Lucie
qui n'en a que 3,18 l'autre et s'il a
été baptisé d'après le dinosaure préféré
des enfants des années 90 c'est pas
parce qu'il se trouvait dans une vallée
des Merveilles mais plutôt parce qu'on a
d'abord découvert son pied quand les
gens l'ont fait exploser à la dynamite
pour extraire le calcaire de la grotte
dans laquelle il se trouvait oui oui
bref soyez comme vos ancêtres
dressez-vous fièrement sur vos appuis
[Musique]
et pour finir le dixième conseil soyez
généreux vous êtes rare et précieux
comme l'Afrique du Sud et surtout vous
avez beaucoup et vous donner tout autant
à vos visiteurs ça tombe bien parce
qu'avec Julien d'entracte science on
lance justement notre financement
participatif comme de par hasard mais
c'est pour une bonne cause Julien invite
Fiona et moi-même chez lui en Afrique du
Sud pour participer à des fouilles
paléontologiques je laisse Julien vous
raconter en quoi ça va consister le
projet trinax est une initiative que
nous avons créé avec mes collègues afin
d'aider les étudiants sud-africains à
aller sur le terrain l'Université du
videvator centre dont je fais partie et
l'une des seules universités en Afrique
subsaharienne a proposé un diplôme de
paléontologie c'est l'un des seuls
endroits où de jeunes étudiants
africains peuvent obtenir un diplôme en
paléontologie le problème c'est que
étant donné le manque de moyens nous
n'arrivons pas à rassembler suffisamment
de budget pour envoyer nos étudiants
longtemps sur le terrain pour apprendre
toutes les techniques de la
paléontologie de terrain et de fouilles
si le financement participatif est un
succès nous emmènerons Valentine et
Fiona sur le terrain avec nos étudiants
afin de leur montrer les différentes
techniques de fouilles le platrage des
fossiles et pour ça nous irons dans le
carrous Sud-Africain dans ces grands
dépôts afin d'aller chercher l'hélice
aux Orres les fameux survivants de la
limite permienrias mais aussi bien
d'autres merveilles du registre fossiles
sud-africain comme par exemple la plus
grande collection de gorgonopsiens
Predator au monde ou bien encore les
empreintes de pas de dinosaures du
Golden Gate National Park si vous voulez
nous aider le lien est en description et
merci d'avance pour votre soutien je
suis moult honoré que Julien nous ait
choisi Fiona et moi pour les accompagner
l'important c'est d'envoyer ces
étudiants sur le terrain moi je suis la
cerise sur la crocs on gagnera pas
d'argent là-dessus c'est c'est juste
pour défrayer le séjour pour tous les
participants Fiona et moi on vous
ramènera de belles images on vous
partagera nos découvertes ce sera comme
si vous y étiez on compte sur vous c'est
mon tout premier financement
participatif d'ailleurs depuis que
YouTube a fermé j'ai pas ouvert
d'alternatives à côté de tipee et bah
pour ceux qui se demandaient considérer
cette Ulule comme l'alternative en
question si vous voulez soutenir mon
travail nous permet de faire des choses
hors du commun d'aller vous montrer des
vrais vieux cailloux dont certains
étaient vivants à un moment et surtout
d'emmener des étudiants sur le terrain
vous savez quoi faire
vous avez le pouvoir de nous emmener en
Afrique du Sud Fiona et moi pour qu'on
puisse vous en rapporter notre éminence
savoir et faire de vous les Elon Musk de
demain le lien de la cagnotte est en
description on compte sur vous merci
pour votre générosité
et en voyage jamais sans ma trousse de
secours et mon orvetn et oui c'est
l'heure du partenaire de cette vidéo
alors merci alors VPN mon VPN préféré de
soutenir cette chaîne et de
m'accompagner en voyage jusqu'au pays de
l'or des diamants des petits pieds et
des cratons il ne prend pas de place
dans ma valise et me rendra bien des
services cet été depuis mon ordinateur
et mon téléphone intelligent grâce à
leur VPN je vais pouvoir utiliser les
wifi public en toute sécurité pour
surfer sur le net pendant mes pauses
cabinets dans une célèbre enseigne de
fast food grâce à leur VPN à moi les
économies quand je réserverai mon hôtel
fini les petites sournoiserie décide qui
repère mon IP pour monter les prix en
scred quand je reviens plusieurs fois
sur leur page je vous vois à mon tour de
sournoiser en me localisant dans le pays
pauvre de mon choix pour payer moins
cher mes billets cet été pensé malin et
combattez le capitalisme grâce à leur
VPN essayez leur service grâce à leur 30
jours satisfaits ou remboursés et quand
vous serez satisfait bénéficiez d'une
offre exceptionnelle de quatre mots
offerts pour tout abonnement de 2 ans
grâce à mon lien
nordvpn.com/sence de comptoir faites des
économies en achetant nordvpn sur
nordvpn.com/s
merci audio de choc d'entracte sciences
pour leur participation à cette vidéo
qui avec un peu de chance et avec votre
aide surtout ne sera que le début d'une
belle aventure humaine le lien de la
cagnotte est en description il n'attend
que vous rien à voir mais j'en profite
pour préciser que ceux qui veulent me
voir en vrai peuvent le faire dans les
jours qui viennent le 9 juin à la
rencontre des jeunes européens au
Parlement européen de Strasbourg et il
est 10 séances juin au rétro geek à
Vesoul avec une flopée de vulgarisateur
dont mon meilleur ami le point Genius et
d'ici là n'oubliez pas la cagnotte merci
pour nous ah non on fait comme ça
maintenant
[Musique]